Je veux m'assurer que je maintiens les
traditions d'être un garçon d'honneur J'ai vraiment
besoin d'amener le marié à l'église à
temps, j'ai besoin de faire partie des
anneaux et j'ai besoin d'avoir des relations sexuelles avec une
demoiselle d'honneur peut-être quand ils sont  plus âgé donc je l'
ai fait où es-tu dr.  dame malade rouge
sur une déception stupide ouais apprenez
une fois de plus que c'est juste quelque chose dans notre
mariage qui n'a pas tout à fait ouais ça
pourrait être quelqu'un de mieux regardant mieux
s'éclipser non juste trop gentille
elle est trop parfaite saint chut et nous sommes arrivés
ici nous devrions apprendre à nous connaître
mademoiselle Wright elle vas-y je vais bien ouais c'est
juste ton type vraiment tu es aligné je
ne cherche pas vraiment à être beau j'ai besoin
être avec toi maintenant je suis désolé que
topiquement chaque cas le ventilateur de plafond je
n'abandonne pas en une minute je t'ai rencontré je n'ai
pensé à rien d'autre
c'est que mon sale petit
ouais bébé
il ne reverra littéralement jamais un autre
pénis en toute équité  tu en as probablement
vu assez pour t'entendre avec elle
n'est-ce pas je ne t'appelle pas une [ __ ]
mais je suis aussi
incroyable regarde bien je viens dans le coin je
devrai essayer plus tard
donc c'est maroko c'est l'hôtel et c'est
tout  c'est la levrette